I've always said that the fun part of
any systems research is the technical details and implementing
an idea. So let's look at some of
the implementation details here. So what's going to happen is
that when a process or a thread on a processor Tries to write to a page X.
At the point of writing to that page X,
the operating system is going to say this guy wants
to write to this X, I'm going to make a twin for this page, so there's the
original page, and then the twin for the
same page, and the original page is writeable by
this process. That mapping is there in the
page table. This new copy, a twin, has been
created in physical memory. It's not mapped into the
page table of any process. It is just additional
copy of the same page created by the operating system as a twin. So this page
has been made writable and therefore the thread
can make changes to the X, which is the
original copy of the page. So the thread reaches the release point.
So when the thread reaches the release point, what the DSM software is going to
do, is compute the depth between the changes
that have been made, and the original
version. The original version, we created a twin,
right? So this is the twin, and this is the original page, but this original
page we made modifications to. X has now become x prime, and this is the twin,
which is containing the page as it was before The thread started writing to it.
So the DSM software at the release point, is
going to compute the diff between the original copy of
the page, and the modified copy of the page.
And the diff is going to be computed as a
run link encoded diff. Meaning that all of the
Page is not been modified. It's only this portion
and this portion of the page that have been
modified. So the diff is going to be computed as
oh, the page is changed starting from here
up until here and starting from here up until
here. This is the starting point for the change
and this is the amount of change and this
is the content of the change. The diff in
the data structure that had been created by the
DSM software to remember the changes that had been
made to this data x prior to release as
you may have imagined already when the same block That governs
[UNKNOWN] to this page which was released over here is acquired by a
different processor at the point of acquisition. What we're going to do is we're
going to invalidate all the pages that were touched In this critical section,
including x. So, x will be invalidated at
the point of acquisition of the same lock
that is governing this critical section. And when
that processor has a page fault for page
x. A DSM software knows that, oh, there is a Diff lying around on this node
which is needed in order to update the
page and give it to the current lock acquirer.
So, that's part of what goes on under
the covers in the implementation. But so far
as this node is concerned When the release
operation is done, at that point, the DSM
software is going to compute the diff between
changes made to this page and its original
copy of the page and keep that as
a diff data structure. And there are multiple pages,
all of the diffs will be created. At the
point of release. And once this thread that was in
this critical section has completed its release operation, we will
write protect this page X. We're write protecting it to
indicate that this guy cannot write to it anymore
unless he gets in the critical section and we have
to do the coherence actions again. And that's the implementation
of the protocol. And at this point we write-protect the
original page and we can also get rid of
the twin. The use for this twin is complete. We
only needed it in order to compute this dift.
We've computed it and we write-protected the original page and
everything that needs to be done on this node
is complete and we can get rid of this twin
and getting rid of this twin essentially means That
we are freeing up the physical memory that we allocated
for creating the twin in the first place.